Todd good morning how are you I'm doing
well if you ever think we'd get through
such a crazy spot with this dress stuff
well I think it's interesting because we
look at these quarterbacks and who's
plug and play and it seems to evolve
almost weekly where you go okay Dwayne
Hoskins now is he a top-10 pick you know
where was he four months ago now you put
in Cuyler Murray is he a first round
second round who needs a quarterback how
badly do you need a quarterback so I
think that's where the interest always
lies with the draft that feels like it's
defensive line heavy at the top I was
just looking at 19 of the top 22 players
right now that I have ranked are on the
defensive side of the ball that's crazy
I'm you know I've never had that that it
weighed so heavily on on one side of the
football and and you know for for TV
execs and everybody else it's not not
ideal for coming off of last year or we
we got spoiled and there we set a record
for four quarterbacks drafted in the top
ten and five drafted in the first round
and now you're looking at a class with
Justin Harbor who's talented but has a
lot of work still to do Dwayne Haskins
like you said you know it's another
mixed risky type thing where you're
looking at the 13 starts and and then
after that well again a bunch of guys
that have talent and have potential but
it's just aren't area will Grier from
West Virginia
drew Locke from Missouri Brian Finley
from North Carolina State Daniel Jones
from Duke and there really are dying
guys it could wind up going the second
third rounds but none of which I feel
great about drafting the first row
there's no plug-and-play guy no not in
my opinion
Justin Herbert's the most talented of
the group I mean he he's kind of like a
Josh Allen from the year ago where you
know the talents there you know if he's
developed properly and then you saw as a
rookie you're seeing is a refute flashes
of him made some great plays but then
the inconsistency that you saw
throughout his career at Wyoming and
then you know Haskins
has gotten better and better as a season
has progressed tape I walked upon my I
was underwhelmed put it lightly against
Penn State but since then he keeps these
he's gotten better better but just he
doesn't have a lot of game experience so
to say that he can you know true risk he
wound up playing a lot as a rookie and I
wouldn't describe what he did as a
rookie as poke him right but since then
he's gotten better with virginianus
system and I probably already on putting
guys around him and so if Haskins up in
a situation like that then he's no
chance to succeed but you can't
guarantee all those factors what grade
do you have on Kyler Murray I I would
actually take him in the first round I
really would I think the league is
trending towards what he is and I know
he's I've stood next to him I'm guessing
he's just shy of 510 but you know we've
seen guys now who are shorter they're
coming in the league League is just more
spread out and it's not about standing
you know in the pocket and making the
same kind of throws you have to make
even five seven years ago you just
you're able to be with everything being
more spread hitting the seams throwing
the ball outside extending plays with
your feet I just I think he fits today's
NFL with a quick process a quick release
and then unbelievable athleticism to
extend plays and to create with his feet
I'm also curious about this because
everybody has an opinion on what sport
he should play but I mentioned this
first hour the thing I would factor in
what sport does he want to play because
it feels like he wants to play football
he might be really good at baseball if
you're drafted you know eighth overall
and it's a safer decision maybe there's
more money there there's longevity but I
get the feeling the more success he's
having at Oklahoma the more that he like
he loves football more than baseball do
we know I can't tell see you know so we
were in we had to Oklahoma games back to
back we had them against we had them I
think in Lubbock Texas Tech and then we
the following week at home and talking
to Linda Riley it was the first time I
got any sense that Tyler might stick
with football he might come back and
play again next year and he might want
to look into his NFL future and so I I
put it out there because Lincoln was out
of it about it he said we discussed it I
talked to his parents I talked to him
and we just we made a promise to each
other that we were not going to discuss
we're not going to revisit this
conversation until after the season
let's see how things go let's see if you
fall in love with actually starting and
playing and doing all the things that
he's doing this year and then I you know
I've watched a couple things since with
he sat down with Tim Tebow and it and
somebody else I think is his agent
baseball Scott Boras came out and
reported that down he's absolutely
playing baseball and then he said to Tim
that he wasn't returning to Oklahoma
next year mm-hmm so you know that leads
me to believe that he is planning on
playing baseball and that's what
everyone seems to think in every NFL
scout and general manager of khonshu
thinks that he's playing baseball but
when you talk to people inside the
football program they seem to think that
he absolutely loves football agree with
what you're saying so I don't know
there's still this little bit of
question out there and I think you'd be
a tremendous football player really
would I think it was like I said he's a
first-round draft pick you're gonna make
somewhere in the 10 to 25 million dollar
guarantee range in terms of money so I
think there's a bigger decision still to
be made but they you know maybe I'm
wrong if he's already paid it he's gonna
go play baseball
he's Todd McShea ESPN Draft and college
football analyst he's got a mock draft
he'll unveil next Wednesday morning on
ESPN if to a tongue of Eylau were in
this draft where would he go first room
first quarterback same thing I mean yeah
he would be the first thing he probably
I can't say he'd be the first pick
overall this year when you look at it me
as the projections are right now the
Giants would be I think six or seven and
they would be the first team that
actually eat the quarterback
you've got San Francisco and Arizona
Detroit the Jets McCall they all either
have a quarterback or just drafted one
last year so I think but I do think two
would be the first the first quarterback
cake and I think it would probably be
the Giants if they moved up or not the
Jaguars are sitting there at nine and I
think Miami is at 13 Moses probably
right now with the draft work today
according to the order if those would be
the three three teams that you'd be
looking at in the top 13 picks that need
quarterbacks and judging by recent
history teams have been moving up just
about every single year to go get each
quarterback so my guess is it one of
them would move up to go get two if he
were available if you redrafted from
last year what what would be the biggest
change if you were the Browns would you
still have taken Baker Mayfield if we
redraft there's nothing he's done this
year that would I mean I personally I
wouldn't have I would have taken Sam
Donald and I I would stick with that
myself but if you're the Browns and you
made that decision there really isn't
anything this year that you've seen
would lead you to go in a different
direction
well maybe the question is if you're the
Giants and so you know you got the
second pick and say Kwan Barclay is
going to the Pro Bowl I know he's having
a near record-setting season as a rookie
running back do the Giants still takes a
Kwan Barkley or do they take Sam
d'Arnaud
I would have taken Sam dartle at the
time and I still would okay you know I
how do you sit there and know in this so
look where they're gonna be drafting six
or seven so overall looks like yeah and
you in your you hit a grand slam with
that pick you couldn't have asked for
anything more out of fake or Berkeley
then you have been what you expected to
get from him but you're still in a
position where you have a cop-con
traffic you're losing all these games
the answer unfortunately is you how to
find a quarterback and I you know
especially in that town that watching
that and the Jets haven't had a ton of
success either so I get it but at least
they have their quarterback
right I would take quarterback over
running back every single time but you
have to make sure that you've taken the
right quarterback because everybody says
well you got to take a quarterback no
you have to take the right quarterback
there remember yeah there's been drafts
where you all of a sudden these GM's go
oh my god we got to go get our
quarterback and you're taking Blaine
Gabbert and like you're just everybody
went all-in on that draft and they went
stupid so that's like four holes Johnny
Manziel you know Bridgewater who
actually played well but but can't
couldn't say healthy does Tampa take a
quarterback are they done with Jameis
Winston three before weeks ago I would
have said absolutely now I am not 100%
certain I really I don't think they do
my gut tells me that they're gonna try
to ride it out do the Raiders that one's
interesting because we all know John and
he's got a quarterback a DD you know and
he's never said I'd I you know Derek has
had some really good moments but I we
haven't seen it a lot of it and
consistency the last two years they need
a lot of other things but it would not
surprise me especially with three picks
in the first round so right now I think
it's they would have the second overall
pick and then 23 and 25 so it wouldn't
shock me if maybe he took in nick Bosa
or one of these defensive linemen with
that first pick and then with 23 or 25
or maybe package them together and go up
and get get the quarterback that he
wants but it you know it wouldn't shock
me if you want to take a look it really
will if Jared Goff and Todd Gurley were
both available and you can only have one
you're pinning me in the corner here I
just said you have to say no I would I
would go the quarterback so does not
contradict myself but it would be a damn
that would be hard everything really
legitimately runs through girlie enough
that organization girly or Aaron Donald
Aaron Donald I think he's the best
player he might he might be the best
player in the NFL today golf or Aaron
don't thank you good luck with the mock
draft next Wednesday appreciate Todd
McShea ESPN NFL I knew I was gonna get
him college football analyst is mock
draft 1.0 next Wednesday morning for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]